hi
i'm julian i'm talking about regular
expression
and basically how to implement them in
javascript so this is what i did
um i did a lot of projects like pdfjs
where you render pdfs in
in firefox or developer tools hack gecko
um
member openstreetmap data in the browser
but this is like my first real
side project that i pushed to some kind
of ant so pretty happy to present this
so somewhat of motivation why i did this
was like yeah you you know these like
regular expressions they are so small
they're so cute
but how many of you really find it
painful to write them and takes hours
for you to write them yeah many hands in
the air so this was like me so like
yeah they look cute they are nice but
they're they're they're really hard to
get right
so many people ask me why am i doing
re-implementing this
in javascript um well the reason was
i want to be able to debug regular
expressions
i want to write my own [ __ ] compiler in
a regular in in javascript that
basically compiles regular expressions
from javascript to javascript code again
and want to present at jsconfigu so it
was like yeah
my talk got accepted so i was and then
actually well now that means i got to
get this working so
that was the hard part but let's give a
demo
so this is what uh this is a jfire
github i o rec xjs if you want to try it
out
so what we can do in the console is
you know normally you would do just
a new regex a b
then you would do regular expression
execute through
maybe you get something back and now
what you can do
do the same thing just with the
javascript implementation
ew so that works but what's
cooler is the debugger part so here you
can write your
regular expression and you basically
have some input and you see
what matches so here you see what
happens so
at the top it's it looks at a and b then
tries to match a but that doesn't work
because it's b
so it goes back then it matches b and
yeah that's successful
so that's pretty cool so let's try
something more complex
uh you see yeah that's that's not really
a regex so let's try a little bit more
cool thing is once you implement the
regular expressions you
are pretty good at writing them um it
turns out
so it's like this and now we can do
hello
and you see it matches in real while
it's a little bit too long this is now
what happens it's like
it tries to you know repeat this a a few
times so it matches
a w which means the character it matches
then it tries next time and like ah
the the column doesn't work so it does
backtrace now the column works
it tries to match multiple um spaces
so another space no no that's not the
space anymore so i got to backtrack
okay and i'll repeat the w yeah that's a
word ah there's nothing else but yeah
i'm already done so
that's it um what you also get is you
get the results of your matches so you
see
the a and b are in the groups you can
share this to your friends so if they
come along oh this is not matching you
can fix it and give them the link again
so it's basically just putting this in
the hash here pretty old school
and you also get a parse tree for
basically the regular expression they
write up here
so that's pretty cool so let's see how
this works
um so this is like
an overview of what i'm going to talk
about um so basically i'm going to tell
you a little bit
how the path tree is built how the
internal node list works which is
basically
what the matcher uses then to really go
with string and see whether
it matches or not then about how the
regular expression
regex object itself a few things about
that
and then writing the jit and some
conclusion stuff
so let's talk about the path tree
the parse tree basically in computer
science means
that if you have some string you give
some um structured representation of
that string
and that structure is described by uh
grammar rules
in a high level what we want to achieve
is we have regex
that we put in we have a parser and it
generates the postery
so let's take a look at an example so
here we have this expression where you
have
a group and then inside you have a b or
c
and if we build a positive for this this
looks slightly so
at the top we have group then we have
this junction because we have i
a b or c then we have an alternative
that means there can be multiple things
following each other and then we have
the character a in character b
and as is that a b or c
so we have the c on the other side
so this is what a parts three looks like
um
the parser that i wrote um it's
completely handwritten
um i took a computer science class on
compilers and there we used the
generator and i was i'm still young so i
thought well now write one
on my own and go a bit painful but
you're gonna see
there's only basic error handling which
could be improved
the thing is that it uses regular
expressions itself so it's kind of
cheating that you write your regular
expression parser
for javascript which uses regular
expressions from javascript again um but
i hope i can
just replace them with um checked or off
or
compile my my own thing to a javascript
function and use it there
um but what i also try to do is for
the parse tree that it emits that to
contain useful information
so for example if you have a regular
expression like
a b or troop and then basically a back
reference
it's not obvious that slash one means
it is a reference for example if you
would have a slash two
there would not be such a group and you
need to figure out what to do
and the parser already says okay the
type is a reference so it's really a
reference and it's reference group not
one and you also got the from two that
means where are the characters starting
and ending
and he got this raw string which
basically means okay this this part of
past three is this
backslash one okay so now
implementing the parser was kind of fun
because this is like the official
grammar from the acma spec
so try to follow the spec so this is
where it starts
way continues a little bit more and this
is the final end
so it took me a little bit long to
implement this um
but yeah it's it's pretty working now um
these are actually just the grammar
rules for character classes
there was a blog post complaining the
direct expression
um grammar is so horrible it turns out
that it got to be that like that way for
this reason
um for example if you have a regular
expression
where you have just a character range a
and a minus
that's actually interpreted as you
either imagine a
or a minus so if you execute it against
a minus sign that
that actually results in something
whereas if you have
a minus b and you execute it against
just the minus sign
that doesn't match because it really
means the ranges of characters between a
and b um but
so you you see you need to keep some
kind of track or state where you have
a minors and something following or you
have a minus and actually a character
following
but we have a context free grammar here
so there's no real way to encode a state
and the only way to encode a state is to
have more grammar rules and that's
why this blows up such horrible a lot
um someone's on a parser so um
i think looking back i might should have
used the parser generator
which would have made way more errors
and more better error messages and also
helped me to yeah to to just write him
easily um i try to really follow this
back as close as possible but there are
thumbs
things that are not in the specs for
example for
javascript engine directory expression
down there which is the closing brackets
is valid whereas there's no such rule in
the grammar
um and passing numbers is pretty
interesting
so this is in the parse decimal
expression so as i already said if you
have like two groups and you have a
slash two that means a reference for
sure
but what if you have a number that's not
a reference
um so actually it turns out if it's an
octal number
you got to interpret this like uh you
got to do
yeah get the optional number and then
use a string character off
to represent what character should match
against
if it's not an octal number you just
interpret the number basically without
a backslash but at least in v8 spider
monkey does
something different it was took me some
hours to get these small details right
but
um it's now passing all the tests
okay so now that we have the parse tree
we are looking at the note list which is
basically the thing that matcher uses
to execute against a regular expression
so we convert
parse tree to node list and stage
structure for the matcher
so simple example is if you have a reg x
a and b
this looks like maybe you have a note of
a type
character with a data a then you have
one of
um data b and then basically you're done
so that's it a little bit more
complicated example is like this
uh if you have like a grouping which
repeats multiple times
and then followed by c that's internally
represented by you have a repeat block
which has a certain id and you specify
how
how much or how less you want to match
so it starts minimum
zero times and unfinished many times at
once
so then you have a new node basically
saying this should be
um the begin group such as okay here i
start in the first index
then you have an alternative because you
have a b or c again
so you have to character a b in
character c then you have a joint point
and then you have an end group such that
you can say okay when i come pass along
here
i ended this group so this is the sub
sub match that i should track
um then you go to the repeat again and
then i could go
there or if you follow the c and then
you're done
and this is the the thing in brackets
is now basically the a b or c that we've
seen before
and you see that from the parse tree to
this representation it
from at least for me it's way more
obvious
how maybe the match are going to work
around is
an odd-like industry structure
okay so um
the novels they look pretty complicated
to build um
but actually it's it's easy to do if you
do some kind of
walking over past three which is pretty
common for compiler techniques
and then you just bind one node after
the other
um so one
one side story for nodeless so there is
this backslash
s which basically matches white space
all line terminators
and if you look up the white spaces um
it it says basically what you what you
should match so like tabs
vertical tabs and then the last point
any other unicode space separator
so huh yeah that's that's hard to get
right right
but the cool thing is there's a spreamer
and people already did the job there so
i just copied the function from there
and that's how i got lucky
and that's also the reason why i
basically licensed
records as regex jsspsd
to be compatible with s primer and also
that maybe there can be some code
exchanged
good so next i want to talk about the
matches so the match
is really the thing that basically takes
the regular expression representation
and the input string
and tells you what parts matches and
or if not um
the way it works is basically you pass
in two arguments so you have something
like a state which is your string and
where in the string are you what are
your matches and also the traces that
you recorded
and the note list that we showed you
before um it tries to do
all kind of possible matches to it right
till it finds one or it says well
there's no other way
and the way of this i try something and
if it fails i just backtrack
it's done by i'm calling the match
recursively
um and if if the trace fails so if it
tries to do something he says well i
kind of continue here
the function just returns and the outer
function try something else
so here's an example how does it work
we start with a state which is basically
our input string abc
and now we try to match that against
this regular expression
so over there we have like our input
string and down there is like this node
uh list representation that i built
before um
and now what it does is it looks at the
first character so that's a that
that looks good so it moves to next one
and now it has the option either to
match b
or c so it chooses okay i choose the
first one
and before it goes into there it makes a
clone of the current state so
we're talking about s prime now
um so we say test b yep that's good
so we move to d we test d up that works
basically where end of file so we are
done
so if that doesn't work because you know
the first option is not working
it looks like this so we have the same
thing again
we come here
we try to match b and we clone this but
actually this time it doesn't work
because we have a c at that position
so what we do we do backtracking and so
we jump out the function
we try to match c this time with another
so this is also another clone state as
double prime
we try to match okay now my slides are
not in red also
so we do we test whether the c works
against that
thing it does we try d that works and we
are done again
okay um and while we're doing this we
are also recording this trace
information that's basically used for
the debugger that you saw before
that you can see where you just do
backtracking and what part is matching
um there are some pitfalls if you
implement this matcher so one thing that
i came across is
basically if you if you have a loop and
you go back
um you got to reset all the matches that
you did before so example
um the the group b if you
loop the the outer abc once more you got
to reset
the the inner group for b okay that's
that's somewhat what the
m specs is but you also need to reset
the counter for the b
so there was a bug that basically for
the first time
abc matches it would still not reset the
counter for this b
in our group and then just try second
new matching uh
n plus one b next time which didn't work
um
also you have the problems with infinity
loops so for example the expression down
there basically
you could say well it's just trying to
match as many times
an empty string which is basically
infinity match
but yeah the the all the engines just
match the a um directly so you need to
have some loop protection which you can
do
pretty easily by just saying well if you
came and
come here once more in this kind of loop
or this repetition and there was no
process you say okay then i'll just
do the other way and don't go into the
loop anymore
okay so now we have we have like
you can pass in a regular expression and
then you basically can
build a pass three yeah we have to match
her but what do you want to do is
expose some object that looks like the
built-in regular expression to the user
that can play with it
so it's about building directx js object
that you've seen before so it has just
these two functions execute and test
you could also think about string
prototype um
match et cetera but i said that's out of
scope of this project so i just
concentrate on these two functions
and that's repetition what we already
did um
and maybe it's you know the first
attempt would be that
it's i mean that that looks pretty
simple to do right just
um if you have something like execute
you just take um
the regular expressions thing um you
parse it
you build a note list and then you just
throw it at the matcher and see what
comes back
but it turns out that's not 100 the
right thing to do
and because down there as you see the
first regular expression works fine
boston but the last one doesn't and the
reason is
um the abc can match at an arbitrary
position so it doesn't have to measure
the first one
but the first implementation just didn't
you know
looked at anything with a certain offset
from the beginning
so how could that be fixed so the easy
fix is to
do some kind of fake loop so if you have
abc
you just could convert that regular
expression to basically say
well try to match as uh as less possible
any characters and then the abc
following and also do grouping around
such that you
record where you actually did the match
um
turns out that works
so the problem is you end up with a lot
of recursion in this case because
every time you do this kind of match
something at the beginning this means
another function call
the way the match is interpreted and for
long strings you really
hit the v8 maximum function called stack
size
so the implementation that i did later
was
reaches don't start at the first
position
or start in first position if this
doesn't work move to the next position
um plus one and then do it um
other things therefore regular
expressions are flags
um so there's the multi-line flag that
you can can pass to
and that only affects the the assertions
for the beginning and the end of regular
expressions
and they are pretty simple to get right
that if you have a new line before or
after it should also match
there's a global match which basically
means you should repeat the next time
for another precision
that's also a cage to implement the the
more harder part is ignore case
so in trivial implementation my idea
might be that you just take
the input strings and your regular
expression and just do uppercase and
then see
where the character matches but actually
this back specifies it's not just
a two upper string conversation there
are also some other
small things that you got to watch out
to for example if you do an upper string
on the character
or on the individual character if it
ends up to be
two characters afterwards you just use
the the previous one
um before doing the upper space so you
need to
apply a different kind of function and
also you have fun with
um with ranges because if you have a
range a to
curly brace and you do this ignore
um case operation where you basically
transform it to uppercase
you only want the a to set good to go
uppercase
and the other m characters to stay the
same
so this is um yeah
and well they're basically more fun to
this so
the specs is that for all the input
stuff you need to call
what internal defined tostring into
number functions
so um here we have an example where we
define a string as an object with a two
string function which internally owns
false
and we try to execute it against ls
with an ignore case
regex so does anybody know what this
returns
yeah match is good um so it returns ls
um basically because it says the string
you call the tostring function
which then returns false which is
boolean where you call the two string
function again
so you get false as a string and then
you match again against the ls
um and then you you end up with the ls
so that's the small things to get right
um there is the
what i got nine minutes
yeah um so but there's there's luckily
um
i could test you from ecmascript where
where we try to get all 500 and more
tests passing and then you get all the
small pitfalls
um so yeah this rec xjs object got a
little bit bigger it's 240
lines of code so it was not as trivial
but it got working
so now we come to to my favorite part
the chit compiler
um so i love compilers and i love chits
so
um so in overview what what we want to
do is basically we take a regular
expression and we really
want to omit javascript code itself so
this means we
implement a regular expression cheat in
a child script jit
which just by that itself is like
the idea is that we can match the input
stream faster
or the input string faster by using
finite state machines
um we all also support just a subset of
regular expression
to make our life easier but hopefully
that gives us faster and more efficient
matches
so for example i said well i support all
features but
i don't support group matches because
it's a little bit hard to get right in
the dfa
no back reference and only 3d
repetitions
and there's also a lot of stuff missing
because i just did the entire
implementation in three evening hacks so
it's still under construction and there
was this one thing where i really want
to get things right um done
pretty fast so i just wrote this one
line without any
new returns in there just how you get
really fast with that and that's
also reminds me of code mirror in mayan
how he writes code and
there's some good thing to it i got man
i got noticed
so let's let's see how this this [ __ ]
works so internally we
create an nfa and dfa um who
knows about what that stands for and
what it is
okay all few people so try to go slow
so if we have a regular expression a and
b um
in an nfa i i explain what it's later
but it's more confusing if i'll tell you
so
um that looks like this so you have a
beginning state with the zero you have
a transition a which means if there is a
character a matching in this state you
go to one
if there's a b matching go to two and
whatever there is
which is a signal flight by is epsilon
you could just go to
end state and the end states are with
these colors so if you have
something more complicated a b or b um
it looks like this you can go from the
first one you can go to first
f from from the series that you go to
first or the third
and then either there's b or you got for
the fourth one
the problem with this nfa thing is you
have none
non-deterministic um because for the
first one you don't know where you
should go
to state one or two or three so in the
dfa you solve this
and basically you say okay the it's a
little bit more complicated but
basically you group the transitions that
are the same
and in this case you come up with that
you can do a transition by a
and then you're in final state or if
there's b you go and also go to another
state where's the final state
so the implementation basically does
this it converts
directx object to a non-deterministic
file automator which is what nfa stands
for
use that to turn it into deterministic
finite automator
and then there's a code generator which
re emits javascript code
so this is the javascript code that it
emits for
a or b so
it's like an outer loop and then we have
this this state 0 the one and stay two
and there are just transitions in there
and if the character
first time is a it does transition to
state one if it's a b
it goes to second one um
and the alphabet for this one is
um a b so the alphabet means what
characters
are used in this to describe the
decisions um
and i was wondering whether um this
could be a little bit optimized
um for example if you think about um
really huge character ranges you would
have to add
all this transitions for character a to
unicode 777 so maybe there is a better
solution
and i just because i'm running out of
time going briefly what i did was
introducing alphabet classes so the
basic idea is like this if if we have
something like
c uh we have a rec expression with zero
and then
one to nine it looks like okay we have
one transition from zero to one state
and then from the one to nine stay at
from the one to tuesday we have eight
transitions
for characters one to nine so our
alphabet goes from
zero to one to nine but this looks
pretty similar to
the transition that we had before with
zero zero
then we have an a we go to one and then
from there we can do b into this to the
second one
so we just basically say okay our a is
zero
and b is everything from one to nine and
then we basically
can make that a little bit yep the
alphabet easier again
um in a more complicated setup basically
if you have more complicated ranges
you think about a number line you
basically
you think out what are the intersections
and then you come up with your alphabet
again
so this is what basically applied to a
regular expression this looks like
up there you have many transitions for a
to e and c
to set and down there you only have two
transitions per each branch
so it makes a little bit easier so now
the question is
if you write [ __ ] code that's good but
how good is it actually integrated in
javascript engine so i talked to tom
schuster who's on the spider monkey team
for firefox about this
and he basically
put this in a while loop and hit it
against iron monkey and see how good it
is
and yeah so this is like the internal
representation and what he said well
this is a little bit branchy it's not
good
so we um yeah maybe we're meeting up in
brussels and
work on this and hopefully we get
something that's not that branching
that's actually
really tight loops and then get better
performance but as i said
it's really under construction so
closing up now um
what are what is there to do um so it
needs some
code cleanup um to be done the chit is
still under construction
um and also i want to have like the same
parser and traversal api like in the
spreamer
that people can deal with record
expressions easily
um so status of project the matcher
works against all tests so it is around
780 tests most of them from the ecma
official test suit
um but i could need some help for
example project page is basically just
what you saw before with this
tracer and hover over so that would be
awesome somewhat cadell out there
bug fixes and also testers if you
if you figure out there's a record it's
not working just tell me i'll try to fix
it
um so but what's more important for the
project is to come up with some cool
ideas what you could use this for
um basically i would like to see that
like as primer is for analyzing trial
script code that this could be
some kind of foundation for analyzing
irregular expressions
and for example implementing a wrecking
up cylinder
way say well you're not allowed to do
arbitrary many matches or something
and also that you could use this in your
maybe let's say development environment
to record how often are regular are your
regular expression executed
and then maybe debug that you should
optimize some regular expressions or
just something else to
to increase your performance so with
that that's it
thank you for listening and i'm up for
questions
you